[Music]
so i'm back to act now from systemix and
i'm happy to introduce you
this sequence about the scientific
challenges
and contents for the program conference
dot ai
it is not a very simple exercise
because the program is very large
very large and
up
yes the program is very large and rich
and
the people who
were here yesterday i think i have
already realized this
at the start of conference dot ai
a lot of work
was carried out by the partners
to structure the
architecture of the of the program in in
seven projects
and i remember a reminder of them
here on the slide seven seven projects
and the logic of the program
architecture was to set the development
of work intended
for industrial
engineering by proposing tool-based
processes for the development of a
trustworthy ai
so
very quickly
it became necessary to take a step aside
that look to look at
where
what were the upstream scientific
challenges useful to the program
and what is some open research questions
so
and
identify these challenges and propose
them to their academic
community
so the list of identified challenges is
very long
and for clarity uh visibility we witness
we have grouped them into
three categories
three categories you can see on the
slide at the
at the last part of the slide
so for data issues we have some
some group of challenges
the link to humans seems to be a very
important part also
and the last one and not the
not the least a system aspect of trust
in ai the three categories have the same
importance
for me and there is no pre pluralization
between them
so for the for the
for the first
one the the data issues we distinguish
three families of challenges build data
qualify data and more global issues
about the data management
and for each of them it's obviously the
the trusted dimension that is questioned
i won't have time to detail
each of these points there's too much
but i will extract a few
for example for for for build data the
the integrating of different sources of
information physical information
simulation and knowledge also
called data augmentation is very
important way to take advantage of each
kind of data
in order to keep truth in them
domain adaptation is a very well-known
field associated with machine learning
and transfer learning this scenario
arises when we aim
at learning from a sources data
distribution as a weld performing model
on a different but related
target data distribution this is a good
solution to constitute large larger
training data set
in a world
where the
the lablet data
are often rare
and
expensive so
solutions to supervise annotation phase
and assess coverage
are very useful active learning is one
of them and we put it on the challenge
the
qualified data also qualified data
on the data set has been
created its clarification is is
essential
this qualification is a large part of
the work to do in order to evaluate a
chain
this is because the data
contains information
or that or does not contain information
and finally because the quality of the
machine learning model is largely a
reflection
of the quality of the data used to learn
it
you you find here
measure of representativeness of the
data the problem of bias obviously
the coverage assessing and the
operational domain
problem of the variability of the
operational domain and so on
and the last part it's about global
approach
address the engineering dimension of
data such as data cycle management
we have already heard about this
the second category um
groups the challenge about the human
interaction
interaction between user and system
mono interaction or multi
multi interaction very important concept
such as explainability and acceptability
i address in this category
these challenges are unfortunately often
only addressed during the feedback phase
on the use of a system i think that the
good idea is obviously to address them
these challenges before the conception
of ai system and not after
in this sense it is essential to have
the dialogue
between designer
and
certifier this is a the last part of the
challenge of this category
the third
part
it's about a system aspect of trust in a
in ai
first how to build ai component with
controlled trustable performance
the formal approach
is is is the
the ground but today there is a lot of
work to do in order to to expect the
formal demonstration of safety or ai
we have a
after after this sequence we have a
presentation about this this subject
it is certainly the most upstream
subject the second family of subjects
concerns the qualification qualification
of ai-based components
and systems
how qualified the behavior of such a
system of measuring the outliers
response
all of this
with a variable uh context and context
this part of of challenges greatly feeds
into batch one so these first years of
the conference dot ai program
the third
family of channels concerned also
embedding
ai which are all specificities such as
real-time constraints energy
performances
hardware architecture compatibility
more than this subject they are also the
principal problem of guarantee the
conformity of the embedded model with
the development
model
and the last part of challenges concerns
the truth
and ai by system engineering in the
system point of view
and you can see here some some challenge
in the last part a global global
approach
i have no time to to uh it's a fly over
all the these challenge
challenges uh i am i'm
i have no time to detail it but we can
discuss after the the the talk obviously
now i give the floor to
to
george for explanations
about how the scientific this scientific
roadmap has been shared with the
academic community and what are the
results
of this sharing
so good morning everybody
good morning everybody can you hear me
is it okay
okay
so we had this
dream of all challenges which should be
solved in this program
and
so now we we have to come back to
reality
and i'm going to present you
uh the results so we had uh we launched
a
call called for interest
among the academic community
to try to find solutions to these
challenges
so we addressed
french laboratories
and
especially
around the two rits in sackley and
toulouse
there were three possible ways
sorry to contribute
from
just like subcontracting a small study
or a state of the art
from the lab
then some maturation of the scientific
work with a postdoc tool
and finally a more basic research or of
course applied research with phd
students
so we had
32 responses proposals and we selected
12 of them you have the agenda
so i'm going to describe briefly
the the different selected projects we
had nine with phd's four with postdocs
and two
studies
as for
the process
each project
each proposal was selected
by the validation of one project
in the
program so you had the list
of the projects
which is decomposed
the program is decomposed in seven
projects so each topic
is
associated to one project so as for the
characterization
and qualification of
ai based systems we had two phds
which are described here i'm not going
to describe
everything one is about
using
optimization
for
finding
evaluating robustness and the other one
is more on the operation
part of the models monitoring the models
then we we had uh
two uh proposals uh selected proposals
about uh building
uh trustworthy components
uh one uh
with systems able to
be protected against patch adversarial
examples on images
and one about
building a robust reinforcement
learning
as for the data part
so acting on data to provide safe system
robust
systems we we selected two phds
one about finding
sorry
extreme examples to be able to find
extreme cases where the system should be
on which the system should be trained as
well
and another one about robustness and
fairness so more
the ethical issues and
bias
identification
finally we selected free project about
the embedded ai so it's the idea of
having safe and
guarantees on execution time when we
embed in real system
the different models
so as for the four post docs
again they were validated by the
different projects
so
regarding characterization
actually we we had
we have a postdoc which is
close to
the phd study
with
lytis in in rome but we have another
uh topic which was not covered by
the previous phds which is about
building
explanations
using some knowledge symbolic approach
to
ai based
components
then we we have a
another
approach which is trying to find
a hybrid
solution
for between machine learning and control
theory which is
in the lil crystal
lab
and finally
the last postdoc is again on the same
topic
as the
having
a
temporarily a predictable
performance
when the
the
machine learning scoring algorithms are
embedded in rural systems
so as you have seen in the different
tables
almost all phds are now
found so we have students and they are
beginning a bit
before the end of the year
finally
we had two scientific contributions
small studies
one is and i will see that it's the only
one which is
clearly related to the human part of uh
ai systems
which is uh
about building an
a platform
for being able to do what they call
autopsy of a case
when they were a failure or incident
on machine learning using a machine
learning algorithm
so i think it's a very important
point
and there will be a study on this
on this topic
and finally another study
is
related to one phd
already selected
with an et to lose a
free ai
organization
so as for
wrap-up and summary
of the result of this call for interest
we can see that
the
the most
covered topic is about building
trustable ai based systems
with
seven phds and four postdocs
so this is the most popular
topic
there are three
contributions to the part data
selecting and acting on data to have
good
components ai based component
and what is
very
i think it's a pity that we have only
one
contribution about
trustable systems related to human
interaction
and i think we should in the second part
of the project we should try to have
more contribution
and to suggest more contribution
on on this topic so i'm going to ask now
frederick
to go deeper
into very different challenges
so good morning i'm frederick jury from
saffron and i'm very happy to be with
you this morning
so basically what i'm going to do in the
next few minutes is to
try to address one of the questions that
has been asked a few minutes
before
which is what is the
readiness
of the technology that we currently have
which is which is
quite an interesting and
difficult question and
i don't want to spoil my take-home
message but my take-home message will be
that
it's actually very difficult to
assess the the the current readiness of
the technology i'm going to explain why
first of all may i
remind that
making transgression system is a very
difficult task i'm sure that well
we all agreed agree on that
and so there are there are different
ways to
attack it
one way is to start from the
specifications the challenges that have
been presented earlier in the
presentation
which is which is necessary and we have
to
to
break it into smaller and smaller block
until they become
easier to define to evaluate to find
metric etc but on the other hand we also
have to pay attention to the
technologies that are actually usable
because otherwise uh will have a a
practical problem
and so uh during the the first year of
the of the project well and i'm sure
that we'll have to go
forth and back between these two steps
refining the refining the
requirements
and understanding better the technology
and try to find
how both can match
and
and during the during the the project
we have been working a lot on
on the state-of-the-art
technologies
and um
10
10 reports 10 state of the art report
have been produced
i read all of them and i
really encourage you to do so because
they are very interesting and they
contain a lot of interesting
and
so what we could uh we what we could
hope to find this such document and you
will see that it's not the case is a
list of technologies and
and
and
the feeling that we have just to pick
this technology off the shelf and put it
in our systems and everything will be
done well actually it's not the case
so i'm going to take the
these documents one by one
but for some of them i will be very
schematic because i'm lacking of time
this is an exercise that can that i can
do
later on
with
more details i think
here i will be very schematic as i said
because we are lacking of time but
basically there are three types of
technologies
those related to questions that are
pretty simple and
and for which we definitely have answers
so this is the easiest case but it's
only for the few of them
there are also a few for which
it's
very difficult questions and we don't
have any answers so
i think it's an easy easy situation it's
a bad situation but it's easy too
and the most complex one for the vast
majority of the topics
we have a lot of
tools technologies solutions but none of
them
is perfectly fulfilling the requirements
and it's a bit more tricky because then
we have to understand what this
technology can do and not do
in detail
so let's take let's take so i have 10
slides i will skip most of them but
let's start by the first one which is
quite interesting
it's about the technology for runtime
monitoring so basically it's the idea is
to prevent and to compensate for failure
of the system by observing it from
outside
so for instance if you try to
if you try to use a system
by
giving it data for that are very
different from what it's expecting it's
not going to work and it's better to
detect it
before asking him to asking me to make
predictions
or if the camera is unplugged and you
are sending
black images to your pedestrian detector
it's better that the pedestrian detector
knows that these are black images
so it's basically these technologies
that are addressed by by monitoring as
as
so this i have i uh
i took it from the related
state-of-the-art document
so in the state of the art document
there are four main branches
this is interesting why four branches
and if you look at them they are
bringing very different by nature very
different
types of solutions
for instance let's pick the second one
which is the the tools for predicting
out of distribution
samples
so well the idea is to ask the system
not to process examples that are too
different from the training samples
the other one is
related to technologies for uncertainty
prediction so it's very different the
system is supposed to be able to give
the confidence it has in its output
both address the question of monitoring
but in very different ways so it's
important to understand
what is the impact of these differences
on the
trustworthiness of the system in which
in which situation should we use
this or this uh branch of approach
and then if you
look more carefully
within one of this branch
let's say uncertainty prediction then
here again you have a lot of method and
i only picked the most
silent ones they are much more
and i would ask you the question is it
better to is it better to use bayesian
networks or is it better to use monte
carlo dropout
well in fact they have different
properties bayesian networks are going
to give you formal properties of what
you can expect but they cannot scale to
big networks and they are much more time
consuming
monte carlo dropout it's more empirical
so you don't have any guarantee but it's
faster and in most of the time it's
working
so as you can see even within a single
branch uncertainty prediction we have
several tools and they have different
properties
and if we don't
if we don't know in details
what are these properties it's very
and
in addition to the fact that none of
them is working perfectly
then we have to know the details if we
want to make robust systems
okay
so let's go to the to the
to the second second
type of
technologies or requirements
which is the formal verification
for robustness
so so so here again we are in the same
situation it's a very very difficult
problem we have a lot of branches which
are
each line of the its row of this slide
present a different branch and then you
have again again many methods
they do not scale the same way did not
give the same
properties
and so they are
addressing very specific
types of robustness
so i have a lot of
things to say about this but as i said
we don't have time so i'm just keeping
the most the
the main messages
we have so and it's interesting if you
look at the so maybe i can i can make
one comment on on this slide
the topic of explainability if you look
at the if you look at the
state-of-the-art report in fact it's not
a state of the art it's a meta
state-of-the-art it's a an analysis of
almost 10 different state-of-the-arts
already published
and
it's
it's
we
and we see that it's a very difficult
question the definition of what is
expected is not very clear
what is an explanation is not clear
either
yesterday we saw that during the first
batch we'll have visualization methods
visualization methods they are more
giving correlation between
between input and output and not
explanations so are we happy with
correlation or do we really need to have
the causality between the input and the
output all these topics have to be
discussed
and here again there are thousand
different methods is it better to
for instance for images as we saw
yesterday is it better is it better to
to use visualization with the silency
map or is it better to produce
counterfactual images what are the
nature of these explanations which
situations are they made for
i mean all these things have to be
better understood because it's not clear
even in the literature
and then we have also situations in
which
we have very interesting problems very
practical problems how can i design my
own data set if i have a problem
and actually the state of the art shows
that there is no
current solution to address this problem
and
it's perhaps in part because the academy
is not very interested by making its own
data set it might be an explanation but
i feel that there is another explanation
which is that it's very difficult to
produce such specifications
and so i think it's a very hard problem
for which we don't have at the moment
any good
answers
so we fall in the in the second category
and
let's take this example as a
as an example of the cell category for
which so it's about the characterization
of the quality of annotations which is
also very important
uh for giving
trust to the person who is designing the
system
if the if the designer can explore its
data set
have some statistics about its contents
uh
have more information about the content
of the data set it's something
it's something quite important
and
at the moment the the most of the tools
are not very rich with such
functionalities and there is a human in
the loop so it's not very critical and
any help that the system can provide
will be useful and there are methods
that are useful so we are in the easy
situation where it's possible to bring
in a very short term inter interesting
contribution to the to the designers
i'm skipping i'm skipping the rest but
during the the the question and answer
sessions i can come up to the to the to
these topics too
so why
is why is it so difficult
to evaluate the readiness of the
technology i'm going to try to convince
you and to explain why it's difficult
i'm going to take this simple example
which is the example of
out of distribution detection monitoring
of system it's one of the important
aspects of the of the program
and i took as an example a very recent
paper it has been published three weeks
ago in an icml workshop so it's
it's a peer-reviewed paper and
so and uh maybe you don't see the the
title because it's it's uh it's a small
but the title is no true state of the
art question mark
and in fact the paper um the conclusion
of the paper is that
the
out of distribution detection problem is
too broad in itself
and depending on the nature of the data
the amount of training data the backbone
you are using etc so you are there are
dozens of parameters the conclusions are
very different
so the recommendation is
to break it into even smaller pieces
and smaller context and do this analysis
of performance and readiness in this
context taking taking it as a world is
to already too complex
and then i will take another example to
illustrate the difficulty to to
evaluate
the technological readiness
so i took one of the most famous paper
for outline
for out of distribution detection which
is the odin paper
icl iclr
2018
and
as you can see there is a very big table
that would be much more convenient if i
can report the performance of this
method with only one figure like
performance is 82 percent because then
we can compare it to other methods but
no unfortunately you need such big
tables to assess the the performance
and so as you can see there are
five different columns because there are
five different
criteria that have been used and they
rank the method differently according to
this criteria
so complex problem can be evaluated in
different ways and depending on the way
you evaluate it the performance is not
the same then for each
big block
you have one method
and one data set
and in the second column and the data
set of the first column is the in
distribution data set and the data set
of the second column is the out of
distribution
and the goal is to detect
out of distribution images to the one in
the second data set
so you have one raw pair out of
distribution data set
okay so and if you maybe you don't look
maybe you can read the the figures but
um but if you can read you could read
them you will see that the the numbers
are very very different so it means that
from when one data set to another the
performance is very different
so you cannot simply take statistics it
means it's meaningless
and now if you take let's say the first
the first criterion which is the false
positive rate so the number of false
alarms
for a detection rate of 95 percent so
you expect your monitoring system to be
able to detect 95 of the outliers
and then for this threshold of 95 you
measure
the number of false alarms
and if you well perhaps you can read
them but i picked them as i said they
are all different but if i pick i pick
one of the values and for instance
for one particular data set you have 30
percent
false positive rate for 95 percent
through positive rate
and then
one could ask the question is it enough
to bring trust to a monitoring system
and i'm not sure it's the good question
so i'm not asking it and i would ask a
different question
what can we do with the system having
this performance because
obviously we would like to we would like
to have zero percent falsity falls of
force detection but it's not possible
currently and it's not going to be
possible in the next
five years i would say
so we have to deal with such systems so
i think the real question is what can we
do with such
unperfect systems
and what could be interesting it's not
done in this paper is to maybe
combine this approach with another
or
i don't know how because it's a research
topic in itself but how can we combine
such imperfect systems
to make
a
global system which is then by this
combination more robust or
i mean can or a system that can address
critical use cases
and
i think that we won't be able to answer
these questions if we
don't don't go
deep enough
in the technology and understand very
precisely what they are doing what they
are not doing what properties they are
providing what are the what are the
performance in which circumstances and
it's really a huge work
that's my take-home message and i
this is concluding this this
presentation
[Applause]
thank you to the three of you
uh
so this was i would say maybe the
frightening part of the show this
morning
we have
867 very difficult uh
challenges that we need to address in
a bit more than three years with 200
people
i find
i would like to start with a discussion
so please if you have comments on what
you have seen i would like you to yeah
please
we take uh two or three minutes for or
if there's a lot of interest we can we
can just take a bit more but okay please
thank you for for your presentation i i
got the message
about the need to
split the bigger problem into smaller
ones
and my question will be quite simple how
to recombine the splitted
uh sub problems solved supposedly sold
into the bigger picture
well thank you for the question it's a
very it's a very interesting question
unfortunately i'm a bit more on the
on the i'm i'm more a tech guy i'm
developing technologies i know how the
audi work very well i'm not a person
very good in making systems and
combining methods and i'm sure there are
people in the room that are that are
better
than me on this topic so i would like to
return the the question to the audience
how can we how can we combine such
unperfect
methods to in order to produce
more robust systems
well thank you for the known answer
no but did you have some answer
okay i have a
very simple question confirms that ai we
have 45 million euros in four years so
how much of all this can we do
much how how
which what percentage of all the
challenges that we have in confidence
that ai can we really solve with 45
million euros in four years
it depends it depends
on the efficacy of the of the consortium
[Music]
i i think that
we we named
many many challenges
i think that some of them can be
addressed during the the four years of
the program
the
i'm not sure that all are obviously our
uh i re
we find results
and publish them it's another question
perhaps uh we we we start with uh
we with that as that data solution and
the the data sets uh construction is a
very important part
i think that we we progress
on this uh on this direction uh very
uh rapidly um i think that's on
some um
some
i i
am i'm the conviction that
for the data
problem uh we we we have splitted the
the the program the challenges category
in in three big categories
data and models and and also the
interaction with the human my my
conviction is
the the data contains information the
models machine learning models is
agnostic
and
does not have any information inside
not so much
so
there is a continuous continuum between
the data
that is the model i think
and the machine learning algorithm that
you we use on it so this
um
the the we i think that with the the
program
they have a very good progression
to to resolve the challenge when we we
make the
the bridge between
the data part and the machine learning
algorithm part there is a question by
lauren here
um
i thank you for this very interesting
presentation or order three i mean it's
a nice counterpoint to the more
engineering approach we had yesterday
for those who
were here yesterday
my question is more um well it's a bit
more it's a bit related to bertrand's
question is how are you going to
progress
or to manage
as a program
you said and and that the call of
interest
might have been disappointing in some
respect because it doesn't
bring the coverture of some aspects okay
no it's well and no it's very good very
good so you are very happy that uh that
this is the the study scientific studies
will solve all the issues that have been
listed this morning
now
come on come on
okay no it's certainly very interesting
but do you do you intend to to pursue
this with the academic community in the
next years i mean to to launch new call
for interest to extend um i mean from
what you had from this sort of
more
more open question and to launch more um
marketing studies or or are you embarked
in in in your progress in you know wow
are you going to extend the work with
the academic community maybe let me let
me answer this okay
for the moment in fact we have just
added a new
call for expressions of interest for not
for academy but for startups and
innovative smes
and we have had 44
run answers and we are supposed to give
the results in fact the day after
tomorrow so we will be a bit busy with
this in the next weeks and months
and so we force launching a new call for
interest for the academics we'll look at
what we can do with startups they also
bring a lot of interesting technologies
huh and they have good research too i
think so we look at what we have
globally and see whether we need to go
to extend it a bit more but i think that
we will globally speaking and when we
will collaborate more with our friends
for germany and our friends from canada
you know that we are also discussing
with the friends from canada then
probably we have
we already have a very interesting
setting and i think we have to look at
it broadly before launching another wide
call for interest for the cabinet
community but that's just my personal
feeling we'll see how what the steering
committee decides
yeah we take just one more and then we
switch to the
commercial
i would like also to make a comment to a
previous question um
sorry for being so late
um
one question was um
which part of the program are we going
to uh
to make uh in the during the program
i i i won't put it this way
uh i think we uh we have the
obligation
to use the most advanced technologies
i mean when we are developing critical
systems even if they are not perfect if
something exists and and can uh bring
the the the the trust we have in the
system and uh increase the reliability
of the system it's our obligation to do
it
so
at the moment
most of the most of the ai system
existing do not embed any
any
breaks of trust
and so um
i would say that at least if we know
what are the what are the technologies
that are existing today and we know how
to take the best of
them it will be a big improvement i will
be very happy with this
i agree
just one last question before moving to
the next sequence yes please um i have a
question related to the generalization
of the solutions that you have we know
that you are living now at
an increasing speed for example the
system that you have built and was very
trustworthy on
4g technology for the telecommunication
network might not be trustworthy on 5g
technology so how can you deal with this
huge amount of variation
they will think about it
well i think i see i think it's it's
it's why we have to understand
exactly what each which brick is doing
we cannot just take it uh as
as it is without understanding
the the deepest
the best
ways it works
yes i would like to add a more
optimistic
thing
about the discussion
i think one important thing in the
program is that we gather several
industrial partners
which
propose use cases and this is a an
interesting methodology to follow these
use cases and for them at least
have a good solution even if everything
seems to be very complicated
we will have some results on the use
cases and probably identify some
mutualization between these use cases
and this will be a nice win i think
thank you well let's move to the next
sequence thank you to you all i i just
want to to put another just another
point
for the the the previous
question about the the
the quality of the the program and how
do we we think that the the result it's
it's it's gone i think that's for the h2
the the problem of interaction
interaction with human is very important
and we have to address this
more than we have done now
it's very important to to to know how
how they the the the humans
build the
the trust between them between the
humans and to inspire
and spear for for the the construction
of uh ai machine
uh there is i think there is a good good
good question on this
yeah
and i could ask
an additional question on that but i
won't because it's time to move to the
next sequence so please thank you to you
thank you to the three of you